you you went to school you graduated no  I failed okay well I had to work too  much yeah right yeah so you so you're a  Dropout wait Zuckerberg  not not everybody can do what I do  though I got no but Zuckerberg's a  Dropout Gates is a drop-off no no no no  no no no no no no hold on hold on drop  down Harvard people like Bill Gates and  Zuckerberg quit school because they were  too busy working on projects if you're a  guy that's failing like remedial algebra  and you quit school you're not gonna  become the next kitten but bear with me  what I'm saying is you do not have to  have a college degree to succeed in life  and so setting up a child and saying you  have to have a college degree in order  to succeed is a false Paradigm it's just  false there are a lot of people who  succeed in fact most of my friends I  don't know did you did you graduate okay  most of my friends who are entrepreneurs  who are self-starters who are successful  in life did not go to college